después de este fallecimiento de la
reina la masa de longeva de la historia
del Reino Unido una mujer que vio pasar
guerras una mujer que vio pasar 15
primeros ministros una mujer que ha
visto la transformación del Reino Unido
y que lo llevó Según dijo la nueva
primera ministras hacer el Reino Unido
moderno que hoy es fallece ella y pasa
la figura de su hijo Carlos que le sigue
ahora a la monarquía
bueno Muchas gracias por invitarme y y
os felicito por este programa intenso
que Vais a tener a lo largo de no solo
de hoy sino de estos días qué le espera
la monarquía bueno eso probablemente sea
una incógnita porque se acaba de morir
un icono de la realeza es decir la reina
por excelencia que todos conocíamos no Y
probablemente lo que venga no no sea
igual que lo que hemos conocido entre
otras cosas porque las épocas vividas
tampoco son las mismas el nuevo rey
Carlos III tendrá que intentar continuar
con esa saga real a pesar de los
problemas que que puede conllevar la
sociedad inglesa no es la misma que
heredó su madre y obviamente los
problemas que tenga la propia familia
real y la propia sociedad inglesa
repercutirán en como sea esa Nueva Era
para la monarquía inversa
Carlos se ha preparado toda su vida para
asumir este cargo cómo será recibido por
la población
Bueno yo creo que la sociedad inglesa sí
que tiene como instaurado ese chip de
heredar esos esa monarquía no no no no
está como en otros países en duda si es
el mejor o no mejor régimen para para
este momento es algo que ellos tienen
instaurado que es un elemento más de
cohesión de la población como vosotros
decíais y probablemente Bueno pues lo
asimilen con naturalidad es El Heredero
es el hijo primogénito de la reina lo
lógico Es que él heredero esa Corona
como como parte de lo que es el linaje
de los windsors y sin embargo Carlos
podría marcar diferencias respecto a lo
que fue el reinado de Isabel II está
Isabel II que se caracterizó a lo largo
de su historia como monarca como una
figura que siempre estuvo por encima de
los partidos políticos y que guardó uno
muy respetuoso y digamos un insondable
silencio frente a los eventos políticos
son más importantes nunca se supo por
ejemplo que hubo o que se discutió en
estas reuniones privadas cada vez que
recibía primeros ministros hasta la
fecha nunca se supo Cuáles eran sus
opiniones políticas Más allá de por
ejemplo el día que se debutó para
decidir el brexit eh recomendar a los
ciudadanos que pensaran muy bien antes
de votar nunca ella tomó partido como ha
defendido que debía ser la monarquía a
lo largo de la historia pero Carlos
podría poner un talante diferente Usted
cree
yo creo que una de las características
básicas de la monarquía de cualquier
régimen monárquico es precisamente la
imparcialidad de la casa real no decir
Ellos están sujetos a esa imparcialidad
como para estar por encima del bien y
del mal de las cuestiones políticas
probablemente Carlos siga con esa
directriz Aunque obviamente Bueno pues
se instaure una nueva era porque entre
otras cosas
los ingleses los británicos heredan un
rey que ya viene divorciado de una época
anterior y que viene casado en segundas
nupcias y que viene con unos problemas
digamos que heredados de tipo social Que
obviamente no tenía no tuvo en su
momento su madre no pero quisiera
ponerle un ejemplo en el momento en que
Boris Johnson en el Primer Ministro del
Reino Unido tomó esta polémica de
decisiones de enviar a los inmigrantes
irregulares hacia Ruanda una decisión
que además fue criticada
internacionalmente
la Reina Isabel pues no toma acción pero
el príncipe Carlos que en ese momento
pues ya estaba ejerciendo como desde
hace varios años todas las labores
oficiales hizo un viaje a Ruanda Y esto
es un mensaje Pese a que no haya una
pronunciación oficial o ustedes qué
opina
inconscientemente o conscientemente ese
ese viaje fue un mensaje político de
alguna manera algunos lo consideraron
una metedura de pata otros un
posicionamiento propio del príncipe
Carlos en ese momento pero el príncipe
Carlos en ese momento era príncipe y
ahora se va a convertir en el rey de
todos los británicos quizás
digamos que impregnado de la nueva capa
de Rey sea capaz de mantener esa
imparcialidad o debería mantener esa
imparcialidad porque a lo mejor esa
quizás sea una de las pautas que hagan
que se tambalee el principio de la
monarquía no Y si ellos quieren
continuar con esa saga probablemente
tengan que repensar bueno si esa
imparcialidad la tienen que guardar bajo
llave para seguir manteniendo su
posición como rey